let's jump into this first story we got
us from timcast.com exclusive video
James O'Keefe tells project Veritas
staff I've been removed from CEO and
board I have been stripped of my
authority as CEO and removed from the
board contrary to what any public
statements may say
he gave uh I think it's like a 45 or
around 45 minute speech and an anonymous
source provided this video to us we
uploaded it on YouTube and published it
and uh James basically lines out he says
throughout my 13 years here our mission
has evolved from Simply being about
exposing the truth with help from some
hidden cameras to something more
transcendental giving people hope
he says as I was going through this
process I reflected upon my appreciation
for so many of you what makes us great
is that we do this work because we
believe we have a passion and a flair
for storytelling he gave a big speech I
recommend you guys listen to the full 45
45 minute speech I can't uh break the
whole thing down uh in only a few
minutes but there are some things I want
to point out
the article says timcast news has also
been provided with board minutes
regarding O'Keefe which included an
indefinite suspension without
compensation and the funny thing is
maybe if we I think um
it gets cut off right here we go this is
a an image that we received indefinite
suspension of Mr O'Keefe as CEO without
compensation well that's strange didn't
they say before that it was paid time
off now we can see here in this document
it's not paid time off there's more
that uh in this image I think I think
this is uh this is I believe it's
something different let me pull this one
up indefinite suspension of Mr O'Keefe
from the board pending the results of
the two-dimensional audit so here's what
we have I mean so I just want to show
you here's the the full video you can
find at youtube.com timcast I don't know
if it was uploaded anywhere else I
believe the video of James given the
speech was leaked to a bunch of
different news outlets and uh I will I
will say this
people are not having it project Veritas
on Twitter is currently down 133 349
let's refresh and just see what happens
if it's the same yeah 1 133 585
followers have unfollowed them on
Twitter and we have this statement from
Veritas take a look at this this is
where it gets yeah I get the most
offended
here are a few examples of what has been
uncovered so far by PV leadership here's
the first thing I'll say
James O'Keefe is Project Veritas he
started it he's the one who paid the
prices for it and I assume most people
are donating for him to do what he does
because they believe in him they say
fourteen thousand dollars on a charter
flight to meet someone to fix his boat
under the guise of meeting with a donor
sorry I just literally don't believe it
that just sounds like nonsense and
here's the other thing I'll I'll tell
you if James didn't do the right thing
and and or he tried to by starting a
non-profit if James just did a private
Corporation and said donate money it's
not tax deductible and I can do whatever
I want with it nobody would bet an eye
at James O'Keefe getting a private jet
not that I believe that he would misuse
funds this way here look at this one
sixty thousand dollars in losses by
putting together dance events such as
project Veritas experience that I
disagree with those are not losses those
those are some of the most memorable
project Veritas experience exactly well
also doesn't Turning Point USA put on
all kinds of dance event stuff for
students like in If non-profits lost
money on one thing but made it up in a
different area that's okay right they
have to they're not everything they're
going to do is going to be financially
successful even if ultimately it works
out to be in the green yeah these show
different dynamics of James and the crew
the people that he's working with that
it's not just some stodgy news
organization I think it enlivened a lot
of young people to get involved because
he's also an artist Like A Dancer so I
think that was fantastic uh the use of
funds the story I I was just telling Ian
we did an event in New York with mines
and James O'Keefe was there and there's
a there's a side stage area it's kind of
like backstage and there's a group of
there's a bunch of people getting ready
to go on and I see James and I'm like
James do a moonwalk and then the whole
room breaks aside and everyone stands
there as James O'Keefe Moon walks
perfectly through the side stage that
kind of thing in my opinion I know maybe
it's silly but that is not a loss when
James was doing these videos he was make
taking a character of veritas that was
something more than just a hidden
Newsroom that sometimes post viral Clips
it was giving character and personality
this is ridiculous I'm sorry it sounds
personal because if this was about money
and he cost the company a couple hundred
thousand dollars him leaving and all
these people leaving like these are the
hardcore donors that are leaving the
last thirteen hundred and thirty
thousand people are the people that are
gonna throw ten bucks a month at project
Veritas that's 1.3 million the donors
already filed that cease and desist
letter right they said we want our money
back if you are getting rid of James we
are we gave because of him and so
therefore if that if he's not there then
this is not the organization can they
get their money back is that legal I
have heard some organizations do it
other times not I'm not an expert on it
uh it's it's an uncommon for plea for
people to be able to donate money and
then take it back so it sounds like it
would go to court I assume it sounds
personal it sounds like they some people
really didn't like the way James was
doing it and um because if they want to
or if it was about money then they made
a really stupid fiscal error in removing
James because he's a money maker to me
there's there's two consequences of this
that I think kind of even transcend what
your own views are of James and just to
go on the record I think the I think it
could be argued project Veritas is the
most and has been under his guidance the
most important information Outlet in
alternative media in the country
going back to you know their their
origin their Genesis with Acorn and
things of that nature and if I find it
fascinating as the guy that just wrote
about covet a definitive book about
covet fascism that somehow all of these
issues somehow immediately have to come
to a head after they just did the
ultimate sting operation on the demons
over at Pfizer the timing of that I find
incredibly not coincidental and I and
just real quick James he says this the
only thing that changed was the biggest
story in their history with over 50
million views and he said it's like a
10x increase over their other biggest
stories they've done so let's let's say
this but set aside him for a second in
your views of him and just look at
running an organization in leadership I
own my own company I own my own show you
got you own your show we have employees
we have organizations I've been a part
of presidential campaigns corporations
here's the reality of of those
ecosystems number one
um I hope they have lawyered up because
by then them even claiming these things
in disclosures they have not that
frankly the Biden feds need much of an
invite anyway they just do it on their
own but they've essentially begged for a
full audit of all their books from the
feds to come in and say oh okay you guys
have disclosed this then let's see what
else is under there and see if we can
just finish your organization off while
we are at it and then number two though
let's let's play devil's advocate for a
second and let's say there is some Merit
to maybe he wasn't kind that was their
previous story right he wasn't the
kindest boss now the story is some form
of malfeasance let's say there's a root
of Truth to them just for the sake of
Devil's argument
you don't take the Star Quarterback of
your team after he just won the freaking
Super Bowl and decide that Now's the
Time you want to have a conversation
with him about being a Kinder gentler
better teammate and and and being a
better Steward of the team's resources
he just won the Super Bowl man hand him
the trophy let him take pictures and
celebrate that there were times before
that moment that you could have
addressed these things and there's times
later in the off season when there's not
as much eyes there's not as much
pressure where these kinds of things can
be addressed this is as you said in it's
either personal or or the the oversight
and Leadership and guidance of this
board is every bit as culpable if not
more so of what they claim James is
guilty of even if he's guilty of those
things how come no one stepped in before
this how come no one said hey you know
what now given we're at we're at a Next
Level here the level of eyes that are
honest the level of pressure that's on
us we've got to make sure we're even
more diligent than we ever have been
before no suddenly out of nowhere he
gets his b he scores his biggest gets
his biggest score in the history of the
organization and now suddenly we want to
have a human resources review that is
some really crappy leadership on behalf
of that board even if they are telling
the truth yeah I think those are all
great points especially since uh project
Veritas as far as I know has their
non-profit status in New York and to get
out of New York you're at the will of
the attorney general which New York has
one of the most activist liberal
attorney general's Leticia James in the
country in my opinion I mean it puts
them in a terrible place as an
organization if the mission is so
important why would you do that and to
your point too like every circus needs a
ringleader and James O'Keefe is this
circus this ringleader to to kick him
off when you are kind of building this
huge momentum off of the Pfizer thing
seems like it's hard for me not to think
that there is something that James was
about to do that the board didn't want
him to that's not Financial James should
file um I don't know what do you think
LLC he should immediately create
something new and it should be a
for-profit corporation and people need
to understand their that they a lot of
people think non-profit means charity
and goodness it certainly does not a lot
of a lot of these companies are just
they they exist to enrich people they
could be tax Havens you can run I mean
some of these some of these biggest
non-profits that you've heard of will
have like a 98 administrative cost ratio
and I think it's like it might have to
be at least 90 I don't know if they may
have changed laws but this means that
when you give a dollar 90 cents goes
into the pocket of the administrative
staff and 10 or less can go to the
actual cause that is and I've worked for
a lot of non-profits and I've seen some
that do 50 50 and even that's considered
really bad some good ones will brag and
be like 80 of your donation goes to the
actual cause and the administrative
costs are a reality of doing business it
just basically means that if they're
like save the dogs 80 cents goes to
actually rehoming a dog in 20 senses
paying the managers to file the
paperwork to re-home the dogs but when
you see one of these big non-profits and
you know their ratio is like 90
administrative yeah that means almost
none of your is actually doing any
charitable work so here's what I would
say James should form a new company and
it should be a for-profit corporation
which means it won't be tax deductible
but there are enough people who support
project Veritas that he need only say
for 10 bucks a month I was just going to
say you get James O'Keefe's premium
behind the scenes director's cut you
know commentary on our stories and our
views and the news is always free so not
not too dissimilar from what we do with
like here's the free show yep I think
he'd make even more money and he'd then
be able to without question he wanted to
get a private jet to go get his boat
fixed I gotta be honest James deserves
to have a private jet to go to his boat
fixed considering the risks he's taken
to his to himself and others I don't
think he actually did that though that's
ridiculous it's like oh I'm I'm going to
meet a donor better have the company
book me a private jet that's that's
ridiculous so well maybe he met with a
donor who wanted to donate to Veritas
and did but also
got took his boat taken care of and the
same donor also fixed his book who knows
but this is but this is the thing too
like one of the claims they made I guess
in these internal documents is that he
used the money do they have that here
let me let me see if they have it here
something about
um like a wedding or something like he
used the money to pay for his wedding
and it's just like he's not married you
know and and apparently it was a venue
used for a corporate party they're just
taking things and twisting it to accuse
him of doing of of doing things that are
wrong but I think Steve I think you you
put it perfectly
I would be more willing to believe this
if privately a board member hit me up
and was like look we're trying to figure
this one out what should we do to to
boot him from the company abruptly to
then publicly accuse him of abusing
employees and that note said some of
these signatories of this letter have
not witnessed or experienced any abuse
now they're coming out after uh the
donors refuted that saying well he was
misappropriating funds it's like I okay
you're lying it's a coup you're just
making stuff up it's also interesting
that you know he's off project Veritas
the nonprofit that we know about but
then he's also off of their uh political
action committee right there's the
project I don't remember what it's
called but it's a 501c4 which they're
allowed to participate in political
campaigns right as we're going into an
election year and who do you think is
like the most dangerous asset to anyone
in politics right now James O'Keefe
because he has such a reputation as an
investigative journalist I mean to take
him out of the organization right now to
me it it's deeply uh suspicious I care a
lot about James health and like just
personally I know him I like him a lot
and I'll spend times like being afraid
for my friends sometimes and being like
I don't want that person to get hurt I
feel like that about Obama too I was
almost like please don't but
don't don't go against the Deep State
barakas they'll kill you but then what
happened was he just didn't go against
the Deep State and played ball so like
but I think James is just a guy and the
organization he created is an
organization of hundreds of people I
don't know how many people and they're
all from what I met at projectors most
people are fantastic and they do
incredible work I think it's like 65 or
65 people I mean they're they're putting
their lives essentially their
livelihoods on the line by exposing you
know corporate corruption and they can't
come back once you take this job it's
not like you can go back into the field
you're in right um it's a lot of them
are undercover so they're you don't know
who they are those people hopefully can
assimilate back in but you know if
you're gonna put your face on them on
the the movement but like I I think it's
important not to put all the weight of
this entire thing on James like he's
part of it and he will continue to be
part of the movement whether or not it's
with this company or another company
uh but I think it's the time to take the
heat off James is now like Veritas will
continue and it'll continue to expose
corruption and if they are corrupt
they'll get exposed thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time